[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi everyone.
And welcome to another
GDL for Google Drive.
And today, we are going
to walk through one
of our Quick Starts.
We've been doing all of
these for each of
the different languages.
Today, we're going to look at
our iOS application, which is
our Quick Start for Objective-C.
This is a really
simple iPhone app that uses
the camera or the photo
library on the phone to allow
the user to select a picture,
and upload it into
Google Drive.
Most of these Quick Starts we've
been trying to keep down
to about five minutes.
This one I timed.
Honestly, it's a little bit
longer than five minutes.
I think that the quickest
I did this one
is about eight minutes.
That was moving at a
pretty quick pace.
Today, I'll probably slow it
down a little bit, just so we
can explain what's going
on at each step.
But for the most part, it is
pretty easy to get going.
And it's a pretty good example
to show you how you can start
to use the Drive SDK
on iOS and in your
iPhone and iPad apps.
So I'm going to switch over,
and just take a look at the
web page on
developers.google.com.
You can see here, we have
the Quick-Start guide.
And you're all encouraged
to try this on your own.
It does require Xcode.
I think I'm using 4.4.
But so long as you have a Google
Drive account, Xcode,
you pretty much can just follow
along at your own pace
or try to keep up, if you can.
So the first thing we need to
do is enable the Drive SDK.
And I'm going to go over
to our API's console.
And I already have a
bunch of projects.
But I'm going to go
create a new one.
I'll call this [? RR ?]
[? Detail ?]
iOS project.
And we need to enable the Drive
API, which we'll find
down here, turn that on, and
more importantly, set up our
API access.
This stuff is actually a little
bit confusing for iOS
developers.
Because there is a step in here
which is a little bit
misleading.
So we'll just say this
is our GL demo.
We'll skip the logo and
homepage URL for now.
But we're going to select
this installed
application sitting here.
It is a native app
that runs on iOS.
Here's the confusing
part, though.
This iOS option, basically, you
don't want to use this.
This is, basically,
for a feature that
doesn't exist yet.
Or I don't know if
it ever will.
But for those of you who have
done Android Develop, you've
noticed some changes to how we
do OAuth and Android, which is
why there's a specific
option for Android.
Because things are a little
bit different.
But for now, for iOS, we're just
using a generic installed
application.
And we are going
to create that.
And we're all good.
So I'm going to come
back to this.
We're going to need some of
the values from here,
specifically, the client ID
and the client secret.
But we have a couple other
things that we
need to go do first.
Basically, we've done step one
for enabling the Drive API.
The next thing is we need to get
the Google Client Library.
The instructions are here.
Basically, it is really not
much more than a copy and
paste of this line.
So right now we just have
[INAUDIBLE] directory here.
We'll go check that out.
Life is pretty good.
And while that's going, I'm
going to move on to step
three, which is create and
configure an Xcode project.
So I have Xcode here.
I already did the Create
New Project.
Here's the wizard.
And for this example, we're
going to use a single view
application as a template.
It's just pretty easy that way,
a little bit less work in
order to get the
sample running.
But obviously, you're going to
pick whichever template is
appropriate for your application
when you're doing
this for real, or
draw everything
from an empty project.
So we'll enable that.
We will say this is
our GDL Demo.
And pretty much, the rest
of this is fine.
Obviously, for a real
application, we would want to
fill this in and use proper
package names.
But for today, we're going
to skip a lot of that.
And let me just go back.
And I'll give it
a home in here.
So we have a nice empty
project here.
We do need to do a bit of work,
though, in order to get
the setup to use the Library
for the Google APIs.
And this is a little bit
of a lengthy process.
It does involve copying
a few files around.
So if you see here, we created
our SDK project, filled in our
products and everything.
Now, we need to make sure that
the API Client is available to
our project.
And the easiest way to do that
is just to drag this extra
project into our project here.
So we'll do that.
It's going to ask us to
create a workspace.
And we'll just do that.
And just save that right here.
But now we brought
in our source.
And for those who haven't used
our API Library yet on iOS, I
would suggest going through the
documentation for the library.
There's actually about three
different ways that you can go
about using the Library
on iOS.
One involves copying
in the source.
That does require setting up
some different build settings,
depending on whether or not
you're using ARC or not.
In this case, I opted for the
approach, which is using the
static library.
And it does require a little
bit of extra work
in order to do so.
But for me, it just felt
like the best option.
So we're going to go and
move on with the rest
of the steps here.
So we've added it in.
We do need to update
our build settings.
So we're going to update
our Library that we
need for our project.
So go in here, and do
a quick search for--
let's see, where is
our setting here?
I'll cheat a little bit.
Switch over to here.
And we need to add some
dependencies.
So one is--
this is the static library
produced by the API Library.
We're going to add that.
But then, we're going
to add a few more.
And let's make sure I
remember which ones.
So we need Security, System
Configuration,
and Mobile Core Services.
And let's see.
So just so you know, the
security and system
configuration are required
by the Client Library.
Mobile Core services we're just
including in this demo,
mostly just to get access
to the camera.
There's some library classes in
there that are useful for
the image picker.
So we have those.
We do need to update
our link flags.
This is a step that is required
by the Client Library.
Let's see now, this is the--
oh, OK.
They're link flags.
All right.
Oh, here we go.
I got that.
I really wanted to add these
to both of them.
But for now, since I clicked on
the wrong one, we'll just
add it here in both.
Normally, we just add this
for both versions.
And the last thing
we need to do--
actually, not the last thing.
We've still got a couple
more steps.
We do need to copy over
this one resource
file from our project.
So if you go here you should be
able to find, in our Touch
Library, this resource file.
We are going to copy this over
into our supporting files.
Then, one more thing--
really, two more things--
is basically
making the headers available.
And then, copying over the
Drive specific services.
So we will add to our user
Header Search Path.
Go back to our Build Settings.
They're over here.
And so we're going to
go look into here,
just to get our path.
There we go.
That gives us a nice search path
for all of our headers.
Make sure that we make sure
this is recursive.
And number eight is making sure
GTL Drive and GTL Drive
sources is copied over
to our project.
So that you can find.
And if you go into--
let's see, actually not
in the Workspace here.
But you can go into Services,
Drive, Generated.
And we need these
first two files.
And we will drag
them into here.
And we should be pretty good.
So it's a little bit of work.
A lot of this is really just how
the library for Objective
C is built.
It does require a little
bit of setup work.
But once you've done that--
you've done that a few times
for different projects-- it
actually turns out not to be
all the that difficult.
It's just a lot of steps.
But at that point, we do have
an empty project set up, at
this point, that we could
use for writing our app.
This next step is really just
focusing on the sample itself.
So we have two sources here.
We're just going to copy
and paste these over.
First, is our header file.
We're just going to copy and
paste that in, and do the same
thing for the actual
implementation.
So don't worry too much about
what the content of this file
is right now.
We're actually going to go,
once we have this working,
walk through a couple of the
critical sections related to
OAuth and the Drive API to
see what they're doing.
Because this is a generic,
there's a couple placeholder
values that we do need
to fill in here--
mostly our client ID and
our client secret.
And these go back to what
we created earlier
in the API's console.
So we're going to copy this
over, and replace our client
ID, and one more with
our client secret.
And I'm going to make one
other change that's not
necessary for most people.
But I'm just going to change
this keychain item name,
mostly because I have another
version of this app running.
And I have some saved
credentials in there.
So we'll just make this--
we'll just add that just to give
us a unique name space in
the keychain.
And if all goes well, and if
I didn't make any mistakes,
which is quite possible that I
did, we should be able to run
this on our iPhone simulator.
One thing is, because this
application uses the image
picker and the camera on the
simulator, you don't actually
have a camera available
to you.
So it does require that whatever
simulated device
you're using that you have
some images saved
in the photo library.
And because of some UI
differences between how the UI
standards on iPhone versus an
iPad, the way the image picker
is being used in this way, is
not actually compatible with
the iPad simulator.
So you actually see this alert
message in here that if you're
on an iPad on a simulator that's
using an image picker,
it's just not going to work.
So make sure if you are running
this at home or at
work, that you do switch
to using the iPhone
simulator for this.
So hopefully, if everything
went well--
oh, I did make a mistake
somewhere here.
Now, what did I do wrong?
All right, I'm not entirely
sure which to step
I screwed up on.
I am going to cheat slightly,
and show you this in another
window, because I did
set this up earlier.
And rather than doing live
debugging, I would just rather
show you the actual result.
So I am going to go over to--
actually, just let
us run this.
And the nice thing is it's
already authenticated.
I'll go back, and I'll change
the keychain name again.
But can see here, you have
the image picker.
These are just some pictures
of my kittens.
That is Oliver.
I'm going to upload.
And you can ignore this
debug message.
But in just a moment,
this should
actually upload in Drive.
And we'll get a little
confirmation message that
everything worked just fine.
And particularly slow today
for some reason.
But the file was saved.
And if you go back here,
we can see the
file ID for that file.
And I'm going to do
one thing here.
So I'm just going to stop this,
and just change this
keychain item name again, just
to show the Auth experience.
So let's just change
this to GL.
We'll run.
And this time what we should
see is a signup form.
So this is our login form.
We can go in here.
And we'll just use one
of my test accounts.
Oops, actually, let's
use a different one.
I have far too many accounts.
All right, one last time here.
I have no idea why I'm having
such a difficult time today.
There we go.
Probably help if I use
the right account.
There we go.
So we have our Permission
Screen.
This is the Drive Quick Start.
It is [? our ?] email address
and our Drive files.
We'll allow access?
And now, we're back
to where we are.
And the way this app is written,
it does, basically,
store the refresh token
in the keychain.
So the next time the user comes
along, and uses their
app, they' don't have
to enter in their
username and their password.
So let's just go back
and look at a little
bit of the code here.
There's only a couple parts that
are important for working
with Drive.
The first is the OAuth.
And the second is uploading
the file itself.
So let's see if I can zoom
in here a little bit.
So first here is this bit of
code here, where we're
initializing our Client.
This is basically--
when the app is loading, the
first thing we want to do is
just check, did this user
ever log in before?
So what we are using is
the Auth controller.
This is from our Google Toolkit
for Mac, the OAuth
controller.
And we're just checking to see
whether or not we have
something in the keychain for
this particular client.
If we do, great.
We can save that authorization,
use it to
access the API.
Later on, we're going
to check.
And that's going to determine
whether or not we show the
authorization screen, or jump
right back into the
application.
So you can actually see that
here, when we're building the
view, is a check to see
if we're authorized.
That call I'll show
you in a second.
But basically, if we're not,
we're going to push on.
We're going to create an
Auth controller, push
that onto the ViewStack.
And then go through the
authorization flow.
The nice thing is authorization
with the iOS
Library-- the Objective-C
Library,
rather, is really simple.
All the UI work is actually just
built into the library.
So all you really need to do is
create the controller, push
it onto the stack, and just
wait for it to complete.
So let's look at how we
actually create the
controller.
This code block right here,
basically, we just create and
initialize.
And here, we just give it a
couple bits of information,
mostly the scope.
In this case, we're
asking for Drive.
It does include the email scope
automatically, unless
you override that.
But again, just our client ID,
our secret from our API
console project, an item,
basically, the project name or
app name for storing the refresh
token in the keychain,
and then, obviously, the
delegators and call backs for
what happens when this
actually completes.
That's pretty much it
for authentication.
Pretty simple, and you can look
at the full source for
more details.
The other interesting
part is how do you
actually upload to Drive?
That is fairly easy.
This is this upload photo
method in here.
And you can just see what's
going on here.
First thing, is we're just
creating a file name just by
taking a Quick Start uploaded
file with a current timestamp,
formatted as a human
readable string.
Create a file.
Set the title, and
the description,
and the MIME type.
In this case, we're
uploading as PNGs.
We do need to take the image
that we got from the image
picker, and convert that into
data that we can upload.
So we just get the PNG
representation, use the upload
parameters to give
it the data.
So you can see upload
with data.
That's the PNG.
MIME type is image
PNG, of course.
And then, the last thing is we
actually just need to build a
query and execute it.
So it's a GTL Drive query.
The insert method is
query for files.
Insert with object-- a very long
name, but basically, it's
upload a file.
In short, we give it the data,
along with the metadata, which
is the title and description.
Execute and our completion
handler doesn't really do all
that much, other than just
change our status message from
waiting to done, and logs
out the actual file ID.
And of course, if there is an
error, you want to handle
those conditions gracefully
and so on.
The rest of the coding here is
mostly just plumbing for the
UI, a weight indicator, an alert
message, working with
the photo picker for iOS.
But really, the key parts to
focus on for working with
Drive are the sections around
creating the Auth controller
and the sections for
uploading a photo.
So that's it.
I'm not entirely sure where
in the Quick Start--
I didn't get quite right
in this new project.
I'll try to figure
it out later.
But not to take up too much
time on today's broadcast
we're just going to
leave it as is.
But I do encourage people
to try it out if you are
interested in using the
Drive SDK on iOS.
Hopefully, this is a
valuable example.
If there are other things that
you would like us to do in
these examples, other
concepts, certainly
reach out to us.
One thing that's really
important--
and this is a great resource for
everyone who is watching
or may watch this in the
future-- is we do have a new
community on Google+.
This is our official Google
Drive Developers community.
So you can find it if you just
search communities for Google
Drive Developers.
You should find it.
You're all welcome to join.
We're very active there.
It's got a surprising number
of people already.
It's only been up for a few
days, I think since Friday.
But everyone is encouraged
to join and participate.
Let us know what you're
working on.
If you have any particular
great tips or tricks
to share, post them.
Feature requests
and the APIs--
we'd love to hear about them.
One thing is, it is not a
general forum for discussing
Drive features.
It is really focused on the
SDK and topics that are of
interest to developers building
on Google Drive.
But I really look forward
to people join up.
And it's really up to you guys
to make sure that is a healthy
and vibrant community.
We'll certainly post some
interesting stuff ourselves.
But really it's an opportunity
for you guys to speak up and
let us know what's
important to you.
So that's it for today.
And hopefully, you found
this helpful.
And if you do have any feedback
you can find us on
Stack Overflow or in the
new Google+ community.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]